okay they're good I Brendan David here
from Western Sydney Australia
yeah more specifically a black tan
that's the suburb actual place that we
live here black tan black town don't
know if I can say the background we've
got some kangaroos having a fire boss so
go to Kingdom sing a few guys
Costco balk eaters happens to be my
place of employment they pay me the good
money's want to know you think about it
they think about them boat hitters can't
wait for you guys to come wait for you
to come back to Australia Theo
unfortunately I missed it oh but we'll
get you next time
Gang Gang buzz buzz buzz buzz man shout
out to our Australia bro shout out to
Western Sydney shut out the Kangaroos um
and bolt gets on my nerves
I don't need 19 pounds of oatmeal you
know I'm saying I'm trying to get in and
out it's too much really you do months
bro you look like 19 pounds of oatmeal
with the eyes brother okay
so you need to take a cart down your own
aisle it's just not my thing it's too
much man I don't need [ __ ] 20 pounds
of Costco [ __ ] toothpaste it's just
too much and usually their samples are
terrible like do you do want to try the
yogurt and I don't wanna try the [ __ ]
yogurt that's been out for hours but the
samples at Costco what do you think
about it come on about this one Derek
dude I go to Costco for the samples dawg
you'll need a [ __ ] membership let him
say what he thinks Brendon he doesn't
need help he's an adult I like it cuz
it's a warehouse full of samples you
like a Universal Studio ride a sample
good you can really just lay on the
front of somebody's car plank on a cart
and with your mouth open
a shark and just cruise through that
thing I love that idea man I like it
look I like Costco because dude some of
the samples is too big I had a [ __ ]
eight core samples the other day you
know I'm saying I'm I'm knuckle deep in
a little [ __ ] prime rib over there
dude you can get a nice meal there to
their hotdogs churros pizza pretty cheap
too oh well I'm a restaurant on the side
we don't need the stupid membership yeah
hires there yeah rugs TV
oh yeah I got a television uh fill with
vanilla pudding you can get anything you
want at Costco man you can get a tire
fill with [ __ ] all right frozen
raspberries I bought 75 blueberry
muffins the other day probably get
through ten of them yeah also that is
Brennan's nickname on grindr blueberry
muffin t-55 and I know that code
language that's how you're sending it
out to these guys he does it every
episode he picks up a baked good and
then a number with it and they know
what's up but I'll say this man I think
you cruised through there you know they
got the guy with the [ __ ] yogurt gun
he'll shoot a half quarter yogurt down
but now also it's dangerous in there you
get into some of the deep areas in there
in the Middle East of Costco they got
people starving in there people in tents
people you know that can't find their
way out they had a man in there that
they found took seven days to find him
it's too big too much going on it's too
big man days and I'm a fan of Costco
overall you see people sprain their back
pushing on you know pushing 40 pound
sacks of of frosted flakes to their car
oh how about the checkout line no it
takes forever forever the dude bought a
car in front yeah 70 pounds of [ __ ]
peanut butter
oh yeah scan that car dude's got a tires
he's in a Toyota Tercel with a trunk
full of crunchy and that dudes trying to
get out the main line right yeah GTH boy
go to hell i King Costco overall though
yeah and thank you for the submission to
super the ones with kangaroos in the
backyard that's no shoutout have fun in
there today man over there at the Costco
dude you know what you could do also uh
you know maybe sneak a couple of snack
here's the thing at Costco you can't
even sneak food into the back I used to
work at a grocery race you do check out
me two on break I would walk down an
aisle pick up everything off the I'll go
straight to the snack room yeah I don't
know bathroom and eat it in there it's
exactly whippets come back to work dude
I do I got fired because reading the
magazines eaten all the food I got fired
it's nothing about Costco the [ __ ]
beef jerky it's insane oh yeah the
briefcase
that's brief jerky or do you forget like
wild boars yeah we look at Willy Loman
of teriyaki break at that brief jerky
what I'm saying this is this man that's
the problem at Costco you can't even get
a quick snack and sneak off something
and hide it no because everything is too
damn big you can't run into the into the
gas station and you can't run into the
bathroom with uh with uh with uh with an
11 pound string cheese you can't be
doing a [ __ ] 70 pound sack of [ __ ]
nuts into the bathroom oh it's smallest
thing they have yeah man so not a great
place to snack it seems like a fun place
to work ma'am